ein Thema das die FDP auf jeden Fall
beherrscht ist das Thema Wirtschaft und
da brauchen wir wieder mehr Menschen die
richtig Lust haben auf Erfolg und auf
Leistung und das ist ihr großes Thema
ist der Bauschke unbedingt wir glaube
ich müssen uns ehrlich machen denn was
unser Land angeht brauchen wir wieder
eine Leistungsbereitschaft ich glaube
ganz fest davon dass ich überzeugt bin
dass es nur bergauf geht in Deutschland
wenn der Sportwagen wieder eine Art
Motivation ist eine Art der Anstrengung
ist und nicht weiter der stieg mal das
scheinbar moralisch schlechten Menschen
und dafür brauche ich einen schlanken
und effizienten Staat ich brauche eine
Abgaben und Steuerordnung die vernünftig
ist die den Menschen auch
wirtschaftlichen Freiraum schenken und
ich brauche auch unkomplizierte Gesetze
die ich im Zweifel umsetze und ähm da
ist ganz viel zu tun und wir kommen
allein mit der demografischen
Entwicklung jetzt glaube ich in einen
Faktor wo wir uns ernsthaft darüber
unterhalten müssen und deswegen habe ich
das Thema heute für die Runde
mitgebracht
mitgenommen diese kleine
mini-wahlkampfrede jetzt nein überhaupt
nicht und ich bezweifle auch ganz stark
dass die FDP nach der Wahl am Wochenende
Rolle spielen wird kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen wir könnten jetzt Wetten
abschließend nein das ist so und
verzeihen Sie mir meine ist jetzt
überhaupt gar nicht persönlich aber das
ist so typisches
Politiker
wie soll ich sagen die sind Einlassungen
von Politikern
nennen Sie doch mal genau wie sie denn
das machen wollen ja lassen Sie ganz
konkret darüber reden genau bitte
ganz konkret Beispiele wie sie denn das
machen wollen wir werden an die Abgaben
lassen sondern die Steuerlast dran
müssen mit
42,2% glaube ich sind aktuell haben wir
die höchste Abgaben und steuerlastung
Deutschland das bedeutet nichts dran
ändert sich seit Jahren ganz im
Gegenteil wir haben die Situation dass
wir ja gerade die Bremse auf Bundesebene
für die Linken Ausgabe Fantasien sind
das ist ja leider so die Rolle die wir
in dieser Ampel Koalition irgendwo
einnehmen müssen
aber wir haben da natürlich die
Situation dass wir daran müssen also ich
glaube
der schlank verstanden
im öffentlichen Dienst in Deutschland
beschäftigt ja gleichzeitig wissen sie
ungefähr wie viele Handwerker es in
Deutschland gibt oder Leute die in
Handwerksunternehmen beschäftigt sind
5,5 Millionen Menschen also wenn ich das
dagegen halte dann haben wir eine
Situation wo wir einfach einen extrem
überproportionierten öffentlichen Dienst
haben wir haben viel zu viel Verwaltung
die Verwaltung ist ineffizientes merken
wir gerade in der Hauptstadt und
anstelle dass wir eine Strategie
entwickeln stellen wir in den
haushaltsausschüssen
ich würde mich da jetzt nicht auf eine
Quote was natürlich immer auf die
Herausforderung angeht und die Frage ist
doch sozusagen wo Stärke ich wir hatten
das Thema doch gerade z.B beim Thema
Verfassungsschutz dass ich da jetzt
nicht unbedingt einen Stellenabbau
vornehmen kann wenn ich da jetzt gerade
ein wichtiges neues Feld hat dann ist es
richtig aber wenn ich Situationen habe
wo ich einfach merke dass wir stellen in
der normalen Verwaltung Bürgeramt hier
in Berlin oder sowas aber nicht mehr
besetzt bekommen weil wir die Leute
nicht mehr bekommen wir stellen und
daran binden dann ist es ein Fehler und
dann müssen wir uns doch überlegen wie
gehen wir mit Digitalisierung mit KI um
es gibt so viele Möglichkeiten und das
Problem dass wir verschlafen alles was
an der Entwicklung die Länder um uns
herum machen und wir sitzen hier so ein
bisschen bequem rum und denken uns alle
irgendwie geht es hoffentlich vorüber
die Frage ist halt nur möchte ich jetzt
ist man leicht vermitteln mit dem was
sie sagen würde ich mal sagen haben Sie
eigentlich recht mit der Diagnose
Zustandsbeschreibung der Stadt ist zu
fett er nimmt uns zu viel Geld ab er ist
so langsam Digitalisierung wir sind im
Prinzip abgehängt unser Chefredakteur
hat neulich geschrieben von der NZ für
die kommen in deutschland wir kommen in
der Dritten Welt polemisch aber manchmal
kann man das Eindruck haben er ist
Schweiz im Gegensatz zu mir darf das
sowieso schreiben nur eben ich fürchte
für diese Probleme wird man in
Deutschland die nächsten 10 20 Jahre nie
nie eine Mehrheit bekommen weil die
Deutschen einfach gewohnt sind ich
dachte immer spätestens seit
Sozialgesetzgebung die Deutschen sind
gewohnt der Staat nimmt mir meine
riesigen ab der Staat ist gewissermaßen
der doppelte Boden der mich schützt bei
kleinen und größeren Fehler ich finde er
sollte nur vergrößer Fehler vergrößere
Notlagen schützen aber dieses Umdenken
im Kopf und das muss bei den Deutschen
stattfinden das sehe ich gerade jetzt
momentan nicht wir hatten erst die
corona-krise wo der Staat als bigspender
auftrat mit den ganzen Rettungspaketen
wir haben jetzt Ukraine mit den ganzen
energiepreispaketen wieder big Spender
Olaf Scholz hat ja und das ist glaube
ich das Problem deswegen müssen wir
jetzt darüber reden
sich zu viele findet kein Umdenken wir
haben gerade in diesem Tisch so viel
diskutiert über so viele Themen die
wichtig sind anzugehen hast du das
Gefühl es findet ein Umdenken statt ein
Umdenken was das wäre mehr Leistung
brauchen zum Beispiel in dem Punkt aber
auch dass wir uns nicht bequem machen
dass wir Leistung dass wir was erreichen
wollen dass wir das eine Veränderung
gerade in der Gesellschaft stattfindet
also es kommt drauf an also wenn ich so
meine Generation anschaue dann kriegen
sie sich gerade an die Straße und es
geht nicht wirklich nach Leistungen
deswegen
an dass Menschen sich future
angeschlossen haben in meiner Interesse
hat sich zur Schule gegangen bin und so
weiter und ich erlebe ehrlich gesagt in
meiner Generation eine Müdigkeit dass
man keine Lust hat zu arbeiten keine
Lust hat lange zu arbeiten und das hängt
damit zusammen singen würde ich Ihnen
Recht geben von diesem Kerngedanke sie
sagen Leistung ist wieder was zählen was
wert sein denn ich habe das Gefühl dass
viele Menschen das ist bei den verloren
gegangen ist es dass man wirklich was
leisten muss und das ist dann was wert
ist es muss halt auch wieder vorgelebt
werden also nicht glaube das ist
wirklich sowas diese also 16 Jahre lang
das All Inclusive Paket sozusagen
genutzt wir machen auch jetzt
handwerklich Fehler das freut mich auch
ein auch auf Bundesebene ich bin
entsetzt nein nein Ehrlichkeit dazu wir
machen sicherlich Punkte also werden wir
bei 50% FDP glaube ich würde die Politik
zum Teil anders ausschauen wir mussten
in den Koalition
aber wir haben natürlich schon die
Situation dass das halt gelernt werden
muss es muss auch den Leuten mal wieder
erklärt werden dass das Thema
Eigenverantwortung einfach ganz
entscheidend ist fürs Leben und das ist
was wo ich auch merke das auch bei
vielen Diskussionen die wir hier in
Berlin nun haben wir wollen irgendwie
alle in die Hängematte befördern wir
haben doch ein ganz großes Problem und
es wird auch momentan auch von der
SPD-Regierung nicht adressiert das ist
unser Rentenproblem klar wir zahlen
immer mehr in die Rente ein jeder ärgert
sich wenn er seine Abrechnung bekommt
wir zahlen immer mehr ein werden immer
weniger rausbekommen sind gewissermaßen
die armen Rentner von Europa und
demnächst muss ich auch noch versteuert
werden also da wird doch bewusst ein
Illusion gezüchtet als würde man mit
immer höheren Abgaben sich ein
sorgenfreies Leben im Alter garantiert
und nicht ist damit aber wir hätten doch
damit zum Beispiel auch Kreativität
schauen Sie mal her Fachkräfte
Arbeitskräfte Mangel das sind wir uns ja
einig dass wir den in dem Land haben und
warum gehe ich nicht her also ich habe
den Vorschlag jetzt gemacht der wurde
leider wieder auf Landesebene auch
abgelehnt aber warum gehe ich nicht her
und gehe jetzt z.B ganz massiv an
pensionierte
verwaltungsmitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter die im Ruhestand sind die
aber noch fit sind die sagen ich kann
noch ein halbes Jahr ja arbeiten und
versuche jetzt zum Beispiel zu
Verwaltung
also wir sind zum Beispiel für eine
völlig flexible
der Porsche der muss wieder zum Ziel
werden für die glauben sie sie können
sie kommen aus dem Gesundheitsbericht
beispielsweise bei all den Pflegerinnen
und Pfleger die von einer Pandemie
kommen die wenig verdienen die Leisten
und machen und tun und dann sitzen
Politiker und sagt naja man muss jetzt
einfach mehr leisten nehmt euch ein
Sportwagen zu viel meinen sie von den
holen sie wählerstand ich glaube ja wir
holen auch bei dem Pflegerinnen und
Pfleger viele Wähler Stimmen warum wenn
ich im Krankenhaus beschäftigt die mir
anschaut dann ist im übrigen das
Lohngefälle gar nicht mehr so schlecht
wir reden mittlerweile bei der
Entlohnung im Pflegepersonal im
Krankenhausbereich von einigermaßen
guten Löhne aber was ist den denn
wichtig sie wollen eine Verlässlichkeit
im Terminplan und dann wollen die wenn
die am Monatsende ihre Lohnzettel
bekommen auch noch was rausbekommen
machen das doch mal ganz konkret wenn
heute einer 4000 € brutto verdient dann
kostet ja dem Arbeitgeber 4900 €
rausbekommen der 2500 Euro das ist doch
das Geld wo wir ran müssen und solange
der Staat sich dazu bedient haben wir
doch das Problem und da freut sich dann
auch die die Pflegefachkraft wenn wir
sagen da wollen wir genau die Entlastung
wie lang soll die Pflegefachkraft dann
wenn sie Beispiele haben dann auch
arbeiten oder die die Pflegefachkraft im
Altenheim oder so weiter also bei der
Rente bei der Rente müssen wir völlig
flexibilisieren also wir werden nein
nein nein
keine Zeit sondern ja sehen Sie sie
machen sich jetzt ganz einfach
ich wähle ja genau und deswegen
flexibilisieren ich glaube das ist jetzt
auch für sie nicht nicht nicht zu
schwierig weil es ein Unterschied ist ob
ich jetzt das Pflegefachkraft arbeite
und tagtäglich Patienten z.B umbetten
muss oder ob ich jetzt im Büro Job habe
wo ich was weiß ich in der Verwaltung
vielleicht Sitze im ganzen Tag das ist
ein Unterschied und dementsprechend muss
auch der Renteneintritt flexibilisiert
werden da wo ich der Meinung bin jetzt
ist der Punkt für mich dass ich in den
Ruhestand gehen kann dann soll ich das
machen in ihrer Zukunft haben wir doch
die genau dieses haben wir doch genau
das beste Beispiel wie viele Ärzte
schicken wir wegen Mangel der
kassenärztlicher Zulassung offiziell in
den Ruhestand und sie behandeln dann
privat weiter es funktioniert aber
gleichzeitig haben Ärzte man genau an
das Thema